hello everybody welcome to let's play
Jurassic hard the game where you learn
to love when you don't have a lot to
love for okay please enter my name my
name is markiplier and alright time to
go by ukulele with Tara
Khun haha thank you maybe I should buy a
meal - I'm the reason why his old one is
broke after all come to think of it
isn't this going to be the first time I
meet about oh I'm the girl oh well this
is a strange name for a girl then oh now
that makes me nervous I better get in my
girl persona huh better make sure I
don't look funny let's see which hair
clip should I go for hmm oh
since it's a since he's a t-rex I better
not wear the fossil get one let's see
hmm the meat on the bone shaped hair
clip ought to entice him and set fire to
his loins it looks yummy - hahaha
hopefully turkic am i the girl this is
gonna be weird if I'm not those are the
comité of a situation ho oh there is
hello Tara kun did I make you wait
ah haha this ha I thought it might be
good word everyone my favorite food is
meat if you know what I mean hahaha I
like meat wait a minute that ruins my
sexual innuendo stop being weird t-rex
oh I didn't okay skipping through this
up it looks like this is going well I
better take him back to my no Shack is
it weird that I can't hear anything
I literally cannot hear a ding dong damn
thing I'm just guessing way what I
guessing that there is no sound there
isn't even an option for sound I cannot
hear anything am i doing something wrong
I'll just have to make this out of the
my own Tarricone only only one potato of
course I feel bad to choose whatever you
like to me about that I know how you
feel but I want you to know that it
wasn't your fault you didn't know that
I'd been shut up wide I'm having a
romantic situation with a dinosaur
ja ja which wouldn't happen wanted
fortunately okay we're having our first
argument here well well you some of it I
think you understand what is going on
here you listen to me and they're
supposed to be sound hanging out in a
second
yeah okay no there's no sound yet okay
but he sounds really upset what should I
do
this is Tom Paine ask him to Hey okay
we'll do it Dutch style I should have
thought about how you'd feel
our farrier I'm sorry turrican ha ha ha
ha it's alright I understand I real how
about we meet halfway
I'm so reasonable I'm the best I'd make
the best girl ever
ah I'd make the greatest girl ever why
with my Moskal mmm cuz everyone knows I
I love the girls with the big muscles
bodybuilding chicks I'm more of a singer
anyway so I have to let me speak
whatever rule will you play
no not sure I blue song you don't know
whoa what they're not you seen a random
song long anyway ha ha ha
for some reason I'm using it anyway are
you clearly I like to thank you mark
Blair hell are you goin ok sob wide shop
where's Bette Oh Tom looking for you
look well let's skip through a bit my
voice is already getting a little raspy
why does the ha
- or on Varga fire love scene haha oh my
goodness what's wrong oh well huh nope
not much really
why well I'm wondering if you the typing
on robear's
are on your knee my god really
another thank you haha my mouth filled
before me I'll never I'll never like
this
Meru rush job Wade bruh just evolving
into something horrifying and god don't
look II know what this is the worst
video I've ever made
look there's no sounds the honest Darla
victim I ukulele up but it was far too
late I can't move
ah - they're frozen I'm sorry
now if you want to read this maybe you
should play for you ha
I'll try to understand why Dinah Shore
is here in the first place
and I don't like dating simulators but
whatever
oh my god are we gonna sing a song with
the ukulele ukulele I'm from Hawaii I
know all about the ukulele - this faster
spirit I totally was it playing ukulele
in the park oh man I am so pretty look
at me yeah we ended up doing many more
it was so much fun I didn't really count
huh I'm glad he shared a story with me
today
I'm glad I could help him if you know
what I mean I'm sure it'll be fine
and a bit of clever words if he will be
desired I'll forget about that right all
right I'll go George mobile Cherica good
end yeah that's a good end
yeah
we're good best date ever
ah I'm so sorry this is the worst video
I've ever made
I'm not even gonna have a splash screen
I don't even deserve doubt the music at
the end of this this was awful haha no
it looked pretty interesting ah
just me in the whole time huh uh I've
been I'm hopped up on caffeine I haven't
got much sleep I'm tired lately so I've
got a lot of excuses so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
more videos it I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
so